so many female comedians will be like oh
uh we don't get the same opportunities
like horse [__] you can jump on any
lineup it's full of [__] people that
are just like oh yeah chicks let's have
them on dude go up and murder if you can
murder you're great well that's the
thing about male or female doesn't
matter and there are females that
[__] murder yes for sure and there
are men that murder yeah just do that
talk about crime talk about crime but
don't go on stage and have a ho-hum set
and a Friday night because it happens
all the time dude it happens all the
time [__] people get up there and
they're just like so uh bro this is your
job [__] out there make
furniture and you [__] sit in the
chair for years and these [__] people
will go up three years into comedy just
like and so I was playing uh uh
an app game and what's the deal with
[__]
Bejeweled and and you're like this
is my Friday night I make [__] chairs
[__] you know what I'm saying kinda
mostly it's just so whack dude why you
laughing so much
you know why I'm asking him why he's
laughing so hard because I want to know
because I'm invested in what he thinks
is funny because he's an audience and I
want my audience to think I'm as funny
as possible because I obsess about it
because I'm Bonkers good at stand up
because it's all I ever want to do and I
didn't turn 32 and then decide to get on
stage because people stop looking at me
because now I got some wrinkles I go on
stage because I I obliterate and dude
people who talk [__] can't follow me
eh
deeper
bro are you blocked if you're talking
[__] you must be blocked cause you can't
follow me dude
you oh it's kind of seems like you're
actually talking to me you know what are
you doing on stage
three years in talking about Bejeweled
my whole thing is when women are like
they turn 30 when hot women turn 30 and
they decide to do stand up that to me is
just like it's so glaringly obvious that
you're that like less dudes are looking
at you now that now you're like [__]
roping them into having to look at you
oh because you're standing up I never
thought about it like that the way I
thought about that was you dude you're
30 and hot and you're starting stand up
now you're terrible what I thought about
that what I've always thought about that
well not about specifically getting into
stand-up comedy but I've like I've had
actually several girlfriends now who
and I've always dated women my age and
never really been a young woman so many
of them have been either approaching 30
or yes after 30 and uh they were many of
them were actresses and that was around
the time they started to be like well I
want to do funny stuff yeah but I think
though in my mind with them my feeling
was always they know that their looks
aren't Gonna Last Forever yeah and maybe
they're not the best actors in the world
so they need like other options that's
the way yeah that's a nice way to think
of it
well these were people I was intimately
involved with so I was going to give
right the most generous possible reason
but however Hollywood is about broken
souls and these people are most of the
time like well guys aren't paying
attention to me anymore let's [__]
hijack a comedy show because I could get
on because I'm hot but don't you think
it's more about survival of their career
or their livelihood I don't you think
it's just like a uh an ego thing yes I
do I mean it I do because people aren't
that deep especially women in Hollywood
it doesn't take deep the depth to be uh
about your own Survivor is it because
survival but they're just like I need
people to look at me I think it's that
simple they're just like ah I'm gonna be
funny
dude if nobody ever told you you were
besides your friends and besides a guy
that wants to [__] you every now and
then you're not funny don't do stand up